when you shaved your moustache off it
was disconcerting to me Jimmy you said
it - that was 2001 when you'd make a
decision to shave off your moustache
you're probably thinking in your mind
this is not that big a deal right did
you go to the producers of the show the
owners of the show do you say - Gilligan
I don't I just King World on the show I
guess I didn't know I thought it was
King well no sony sony do you go to Sony
or do you go to you someone there who
once I was in the makeup room just
before we were taping the fifth show
that day we tape five shows a day
normally two days in a row three weeks
on one week off and before the fifth so
I said I'm gonna shave my mustache
that's right cut off half were you just
sick of the mustache I just did it on a
whim right and then the producer came
over oh God
I said do you want me to come out with
half he says oh no no not have so I came
out and half the people in the audience
didn't notice immediately Wow I went
home my wife my son and my daughter were
sitting in the kitchen and they didn't
notice immediately and I chatted for a
few minutes and I said anybody notice
anything different about dad and then my
wife oh my god you shaved your moustache
yeah and my son it was like 10 at the
time I think I started to cry it was
such a bright shot for some reason on
you know I'm not a big mustache guy I
had a mustache two years ago but I'm not
a big because there it's annoying and
you know these people can't pull it off
well don't you notice too that guys with
mustaches a lot of times they as an
announcer they're unwilling to move
their mouth they want to keep it
straight and keep their mustache looking
well and it sort of affects the way they
speak even so I'm not a fan of the
message but would you it worked it was
it was a betrayal line when you shave
that mustache I actually filed the
class-action lawsuit
people still ask me at the studio they
say
and usually it's guys in the audience
who have mustaches or beards or full
beards and mustaches days are you gonna
grow it back but when are you gonna grow
some things are comforting I found your
mustache comfort and and everything in
the in the game show business - is
likability and how much do you trust the
guy after the game show scandals it
became about trust and that's where
jeopardy came out of jeopardy was a
direct answer out of the game show
scandals from what I remember the
history of Jeopardy yeah Merv's wife
Merv's wife said hey if we give the
answers then we can't be accused of
cheating because people will we're
giving them the answers Murph says oh my
god what do you mean we can't do that
what do you mean
the answer is 5280 there's your answer
how many feet in a mile all right boom
the murder of had a wife to audition for
for the job no no you were you were
working in games after you graduate
college you go into radio and thus what
CBC for AC for ten years or so here 12
years I came to the United States and 73
to host wizard of odds
Alan Thicke was one of the writers are
you still close with Alan Thicke yes
well not that close but I mean we're
friendly and Alan Thicke gave you your
break he made you the host of wizard of
odds he was a fan of yours well I had
hosted a daily talk talk variety show in
Toronto and Alan and his singing partner
used to appear as guests on the program
what made you give up your dream of
being a doctor or let's say a more
legitimate profession to get into then I
got into it because I needed a job to
help pay for my tuition at university
and tuition was a whopping five hundred
dollars a year right but you had no
money I had no money and now you went
into TV I got a job at the CBC and they
said what do you mean you walk into the
CBC and you're like hey I'm a pretty
polished guy almost when I auditioned
for a summer announcer job
and they hired me and then they they had
two openings that came up in February on
their permanent staff and they offered
me one of them and I said I'll take it
if I can finish my college and they said
okay so I'd go to school in the morning
9:00 till noon and then I'd work the
4:00 to 12:00 shift what gave you the
confidence to walk into the CBC when
you're clearly a novice you've never
done this kind of thing before do people
just say to you boy you sound like a
radio announcer or a television
announcer days that I had done well in
debates at school and in public speaking
contests at school but that was about it
and I auditioned for a private radio
station before the CBC and the guy said
well that was pretty good but we have
some of the top announcers in Canada on
our staff and you have no experience
whatsoever so we're gonna pass on you I
said oh thank you very much but you went
out there and you got a job at the CBC
being a completely see that's what is
awful about the business that you could
be a trained professional my father used
to tell me this he says and he goes the
local garbage man could walk in and take
your job because why do you bring up
local garbage man because I did that and
Cincinnati Ohio that is correct
you answer all my questions in answer
form so it really is an amazing story
that you could go in there and get a job
and then you do that for 12 years and
then Alan Thicke discovers you and then
you become known as a game show host
because your host wizard of odds that
lasts what a year lasted one year and it
was replaced the following Monday by
high rollers which I wound up hosting
for four and a half years thank God for
high rollers did you think after Wizard
of odds that's it my career is over
almost they called to cancel the program
on the day that I put it I signed the
final papers on my first house oh my god
always works that way they say don't buy
a house jinx yeah but then I been
cancelled twice and replaced myself
twice on network television so it worked
out pretty well for me I see what is it
Ralph quick routes Trebek he's got to
get out of here
quickly if these people are so smart to
play the game how come so many 0 out
like isn't the basic rule at least leave
a dollar at the end of the game it's
true a lot of that my father goes nuts
of my father watches jeopardy every
night he knows you better than you know
you
and he goes coasters pit I get a lecture
on these people they don't know how to
but you have a dollar left well because
it was early days Mataji somebody
figured out that hey they're gonna bet
at all and I'm gonna leave myself a buck
right and it started a trend and
everybody thinks that it's like when we
had Chuck Forrest as the champion on the
program he would jump all over the board
and so all the newcomers say oh well the
way to succeed is to jump all over the
board so drive you nuts yeah it drives
me nuts because if you because you don't
know what the category is all about
right
the writers get very creative just as no
writers do you say oh with that oh okay
that oh oh that's where they're going it
drives me nuts
because as smart as they are as ralph
says they're idiots